[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview then a first look at what is on
the front pages as they arrive and
tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with the new statesman's
political editor stephen bush and the
spectators economics correspondent kate
andrews there they are we'll chat to
them in a moment we will take a look at
those front pages first though for you
starting with the i which quotes that
heartbreaking statement released this
evening by sir david's family in which
they say our hearts are shattered
in fact it's an almost identical
headline on the front of the mirror
similarly the metro says quite simply we
are broken
an express lifts from that statement as
well nobody should die in that way
nobody
here's your daily mail for monday asking
why the suspect wasn't flagged sooner
given that he was sent on anti-terror
mentoring programmes
the auction post speaks to kim ledbeter
the sister of the murdered mp joe cox
she now represents the same constituency
of course herself an mp she says mps are
human beings too
and china's testing of a nuclear-capable
hypersonic missile has alarmed u.s
intelligence sources that's according to
the ft
and i'm joined tonight by stephen bush
and kate andrews good to see you both um
what a a miserable weekend it has been
and this evening just heartbreaking that
statement released um by the family of
sir david it's covered on all the front
pages let's take a look at the front of
the daily express kate nobody should die
in that way
nobody a quote from the statement and
a lovely picture there of david with his
wife julia
yes
absolutely tragic here we have a formal
statement from the whole family led by
lady julia you can tell that the family
is still very much in shock and absolute
dismay we've all seen the photos this
weekend that were released of sir david
just weeks ago at one of his daughter's
wedding lovely photos of the family to
think you could go from that kind of
happiness to this utter and senseless
tragedy is very difficult for most of us
to understand the family is calling for
tolerance and kindness at this time and
and no doubt the vast majority of people
are continuing to give that and putting
um you know politics and the rest of it
to the side and and honoring and his his
legacy which was merely a 40-year
parliamentary career tomorrow boris
johnson's going to be leaving tributes
in the house of commons where we're
going to hear from more mps a minute of
silence will be held and the common
speaker lindsey hoyle says that sir
david will be honored with a code of
arms and parliament the same happened
for joe cox when she was tragically
murdered several years ago you know
horrible reminder that to be a member of
parliament these days especially is in
many ways to put your safety on the line
it shouldn't be that way i'm sure we'll
come on to talk about that with some of
the other headlines in the papers but um
you know really poignant and tragic
statement out from his family
yeah something that stood out uh to me
personally from that statement and you
touched on it on it there was uh
that line that he was a patriot and a
man of peace so we asked people to set
aside their differences and show
kindness and love to all and what did
you make of the words from the family
stephen tonight
well they were very touching and i think
also
in some ways unsurprising because i
think the thing that the most people at
westminster would say you know whether
they knew to david well or they'd met
him uh only briefly was that he was a
man who was immensely kind and yeah
someone who took real care to be
courteous to essentially everybody i
think there are yeah
very few politicians who who would
genuinely have inspired as much
affection among their colleagues you
know across across the political divide
as he did so i think it's
a very good statement but one which i
think is also very in keeping with with
uh with the politician who was was so
loved by so many of his colleagues um
i'm just staying with you stephen how do
you think the debate today has moved on
in terms of uh the safety and security
of mps um pretty patel was on sky news
earlier i didn't really give any
concrete examples of what was being done
but obviously reviews are in place and
and there is talk about police
protection at constituency surgeries it
all seems a bit piecemeal at the moment
doesn't it
yeah and i think
you know i think the thing that lots of
mps a cross across parliament feel right
is that although um
this is not new in a sense right and
then uh
at the start of the 1980s uh three mps
were killed by acts of terror uh you
know with much less of a gap between
them but in each case the killing of
very neat in 1979 uh the the killing of
a unionist mp in 1981 and the killing of
anthony berry in the brighton bombing in
1984 you saw quite big security changes
the parliament we know we know now of
course is surrounded by this wall of
steel in part because of the killing of
arie neve uh in in his in his car in in
the parliamentary estate
party conference is now surrounded by
this wall of steel because of the
brighton bombing and you know it's not
just the assassination of joe [ __ ] it's
the
killing of nigel jones's uh a it's the
uh
yeah the attack on stephen tim's which
he thankfully survived so i think there
is a real need um
for the parliamentary authorities and
for the government to to grasp this
issue but of course the problem is mps
understandably do want to be able to
maintain that very close physical
proximity to their constituents which
make it a very difficult um security
challenge they understandably don't want
their surgeries to become like the
palace of westminster where you know
it's very hard to get in you have this
huge sort of security apparatus around
it and although that is of course
necessary it does unfortunately make
parliament a more remote place now than
it was in the 70s and 60s um kate uh
something gordon brown said today um uh
uh stuck with me this is an attack on
our democracy he said the answer isn't
less democracy and that's the conundrum
isn't it
yeah absolutely um it's it's always
interesting to compare
my my home country america and the way
politics operates there to the uk and
one start contrast um is the
accountability that westminster has may
not always feel that way but it's much
more accountable than politics is uh in
washington dc and i think one of the
major reasons for that is the open
accessibility to mps uh the fact that it
is actually possible to speak to one of
your representatives the fact that they
go out and speak to all kinds of members
of the community that there's that open
communication and it's devastating to
think that for very good reasons um
involving security that we've learned
the hardest way over this weekend some
of that might need to be pulled back and
there's obviously going to be a balance
here you've seen multiple mps come out
on social media over the weekend saying
that their job now is you know to uphold
democracy to continue to put themselves
out there but they know if they're doing
that with increasing risks and i think
that's the real tragedy here is there
there are plenty of countries free
countries that have functioning
democracies where still it is harder to
speak to your elected representatives
and that's something very special in
many ways very unique to the united
kingdom it's tragic i think that might
have to be scaled back yeah and
something obviously we're very proud of
and and don't want to
to have diminished um let's look at the
front of the daily mail um stephen we
can't go into too much detail obviously
about the investigation we don't want to
speculate but it has been uh reported
widely this weekend that ali harbi ali
was referred to uh the prevent scheme
and the headline in the daily mail so
why didn't anyone stop him
right yes obviously in terms of the
specific facts of this case it's a live
uh court case and yeah much more may
come out
but you know
i think
it's not reasonable to expect the
government to be able to um not only
successfully identify every potential
threat but to be exactly able to
anticipate what the difference between
you know um
someone who um
is dabbling in
you know geodistal or fire up far-right
materials online because those are at
the moment the two big um
uh terrorist threats we face in the
united kingdom it's what it's it's not i
think particularly reasonable uh to
expect that the government should
necessarily not only be able to identify
and locate potential threats but be able
to exactly stop and predict every single
one of them um so i'm afraid i think
actually the male front pages is
somewhat unreasonable it's a positive
sign that prevent had uh yeah if it
turns out that actually prevent was
aware of this person that is actually a
broadly positive sign it's obviously an
awful set of circumstances but but but
unfortunately that is you know you know
in a liberal democracy probably the most
you can expect is that um your
counter-terrorist system will will spot
pretty much every threat but will only
be able to stop most of them
unfortunately yeah the front of the
yorkshire post um also talks about about
this um
uh kate and it's interesting here in the
home secretary today saying that there
is a a review ongoing into the prevent
strategy
yes and it looks like that's going to be
um increased and and and better
scrutinized since this horrible attack
occurred and the home secret secretary
pretty patel today has been speaking
about all kinds of security issues
including re-examining prevent including
the possibility of of adding more
security for mps when they conduct their
surgeries i think the interesting
comments here are from former justice
secretary robert buckland who was in the
role until just a few weeks ago who's
talking about how there needs to be more
in cooperation and interconnectivity
between schools the health service and
other public agencies and that it can't
simply be security forces that are
responsible for this but you have to
have an interconnected web realistically
to try to join up all the dots to try to
catch people before they commit such a
heinous act i think stephen makes a very
important difficult but important point
about in a free society that balance
between security and liberty is a very
very delicate one but i suspect we'll
find as we scrutinize prevent that there
is more that can be done and more links
that can be drawn together and and
hopefully um our politicians will take
this as an opportunity to significantly
improve the system
okay um just before the break i want to
move on to a different story it's on the
front of the financial times uh stephen
uh this is a worrying headline isn't it
china's leap in hypersonic missile
technology uh apparently is worrying uh
intelligence services in the us
yes this is um yeah from a global
political perspective this is far away
the biggest story in not just in any of
the british papers but
across the world right uh this
hypersonic missile which is one that
essentially goes up into space then
comes back down again which means that
it can avoid most of the anti-ballistic
technology than uh the united states and
other defense superpowers have built and
more importantly this appears to have
completely caught uh us intelligence uh
on the hop yeah one one washington
correspondent for politico said well
this is like sputnik and of course the
sputnik launch famously really took the
united states about because they had
really underestimated the extent of the
soviet advance in the space race so this
is a you know a huge moment um further
of course heightens the tensions between
the united states and china and of
course
further increases the possibility uh
than china will feel than they oh you
know do have a march on the us and that
may of course lead to a major
miscalculation uh in taiwan so it's a a
big important story and a dangerous time
for for all of us across the world yeah
plenty more on that in the ft uh for the
moment thank you both uh coming up after
the break could russia help the uk bring
the gas crisis to an end we'll be
discussing that and more in a couple of
minutes
[Music]
hello again part two of the press
preview stephen and kate still with us
let's turn to the
metro kate uh russia
ready to come to the uk's rescue this is
good news isn't it
well i don't know about that jonathan
it's mixed
um well look something that we've
suspected for quite some time and the uh
russian ambassador to the uk has just
come out with this morning um
essentially admitting more or less uh
that russia is ready to funnel uh more
natural gas at the uk's way but in
exchange for that it wants its pipeline
confirmed the nordstrom 2 pipeline which
is supposed to run gas from russia
to the european union union through the
baltic sea
is something that russia's been trying
to sign off for quite some time and it's
been opposed by many european countries
and the united states over fears around
energy security and also the upper hand
that that gives russia um but we do have
this global shortage of gas we know that
russia has been turning off the taps
it's been making the situation worse um
and this is going to be a real crunch
point especially for european countries
because the cost of living crisis
many would argue it's already arrived
it's going to get worse this winter the
cost of energy is going up there's this
global shortage is what happens when you
turn the world's economy off and then on
again and i think it's almost a game of
chicken whether or not politicians are
going to hold out and accept and
tolerate some of those higher prices or
try to deal with them domestically or
whether or not politicians are going to
turn russia's way and say actually yes
please top up our supplies so that costs
come down for consumers it's really
going to be a geopolitical issue as well
as a domestic one and i think uh things
could get uh quite quite difficult on
the political scene not just
domestically but between european
leaders stephen
yeah i mean this is this is not just
about this short term uh energy crisis
you know created for the reasons that k
outlines very well there we've had
essentially the global economy waking
back up and going oh god we need power
and therefore turning on the gas coupled
with what has been a very non-windy
season as you know if you if you think
about when you're walking about outside
right there is a reason why
a country like the united kingdom which
has made huge strides forward with
renewables but it hasn't been that sunny
it hasn't been that windy so we are
unfortunately producing less energy than
we are now the big test both for us uh
but but across europe is look do
politicians use this moment to go okay
we need to you know have more renewables
and also use actually the most reliable
but actually green um sources of
excellent energy which is nuclear power
or do you sort of go for the quick the
politically easy because one of the
weird ironies is that people are much
more relaxed about coal and gas
something which uh if they do even if
they work fine have a 100 chance of
eventually wiping out all life on earth
versus nuclear power which i should have
a very very small chance of causing of
causing uh those problems um
but yeah you there will be a lot of
pressure on politicians around the world
as kate says this is very much not just
a british situation actually here we're
quite lucky that quasi quarten has
talked very openly and bravely about the
need for new nuclear but you have a
situation where in belgium they're
they're weaning themselves off um
nuclear power and going back to heavy
emitting power sources like gas and from
a geopolitical perspective this does of
course um massively strengthen uh
russia's hand in these games of power
politics which you know is particularly
difficult for the united kingdom because
we've had quite a um uh principle and
hawkish stance on on on that country's
activities particularly in the in the
ukraine
so it could be a very cold environment
both metaphorically and literally for
the united kingdom